[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
[Music]
[Applause]
everybody
[Music]
[Applause]
's working time
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
what is popping everybody my name is
Justin Woodward co-founder of black
voice and gaming and the mix as well as
one of the advisors on the black game
developer fund I'm going to tell you a
little bit about black voice and gaming
Black voice and gaming is a non-profit
organization that was created to inspire
and cultivate Talent as well as help
video game developers and creators have
opportunities for funding
discoverability marketing visibility for
their games and just Network in the
culture of game development this show is
really really awesome we have awesome
guests awesome games that we're going to
be sharing with you guys it wouldn't
happen if you guys weren't checking us
out also shout out to all of our
sponsors and the folks who are
broadcasting this event check out the
steam page follow us on Twitter all
those things and that's it for me
it's all about the games it's all about
the developers so take it away Destiny
and Derek it's going to be a great show
thanks for the intro Jay what's up y'all
as always it's great to be back here
co-hosting black voices and gaming
especially during the celebration of
Black History Month I'm always honored
to help showcase some of the best talent
out there my name is Destiny and I do a
lot of stuff but one of the things I'm
most proud of is being a host here and
over at level one gaming a
minority-owned organization that focuses
on gaming news entertainment and all
things geek culture today I'm happy to
be sharing hosting duties with a super
talented person I'm going to toss the
mic over to him so he can introduce
himself
thank you Destiny and I have to agree
with you to be back on the digital stage
for another great show is so exciting
I'm thrilled to be here during Black
History Month celebrating some excellent
developers hello everyone my name is
Derek Fields I'm the founder and game
director of waking games as well as an
advisor to Black voices in gaming now
before we start we want to give a shout
out to our partners for today's
first
I'd like to thank our silver sponsor
sponsors for their support
PlayStation
listen I remember the first time I got
my PlayStation I had the PS1 and I still
use my PS3 to this day you can't tell me
anything also
Xbox I love my Xbox Xbox game pass give
me all the games
Riot what would you do without Riot
listen it's in the name like it just it
it says excitement so think you think
you thank you to all of them for being
silver sponsors and we also want to
thank some of our fantastic other
sponsors who have been with us since the
beginning raw Fury who helped get this
series started from it becoming a
showcase to it being a non-profit
organization we'd also like to think
Razer and Wilson sosini listen I think I
got that right it kind of just rolled
off my tongue Derek did I get that right
so see yeah you get it thank you thank
you I feel like I should have like um
like a pasta and wine because it sounds
very Italian but if it's not I'm sorry
but it does it just sounds so good all
right also let's jump into our bundles
because this is the first time I think
we've ever had something like this
happen and if we haven't forgive me but
this is the first time I'm aware of it
and I'm super excited about it Amazon
one is supporting us by creating a Black
History Month bundle just to celebrate
Black game developers throughout their
Prime gaming bundle and listen all of
these games
are so incredible you have to check them
out not only is Prime and Amazon helping
us Amazon Prime but humble bundo who has
continued to support us and our devs
they're putting together a bundle
and listen when I tell you they're
putting together a bundle you better
believe that they're going to have some
incredible games in there and they're
all doing this to help celebrate Black
voices in gaming and just black
developers in general so we just want to
say thank you so much for actually
taking the time to put this together
it's really really important and I hope
everybody grabs their phone because you
need to go ahead and grab those QR codes
like there's no I know your phone is
sitting right beside you and if it's not
sitting beside you you're scrolling on
it get off the tick tock
and grab those QR codes
now I I know I've said a lot and I just
have a few more things to say because we
cannot end this without saying thank you
to our wonderful broadcasting Partners
twitch gaming IGN
Steam
Gamespot and game jolt
and speaking of games and steam don't
forget to check out the mix event page
where you can learn more about black
voices and gaming and about the
available games you can add them to your
wish list remember that's super
important it always helps steam's
algorithm that needs us know that the
games are on and popping and they're
super popular and people are excited to
get them so remember to wish less it
helps the devs a lot and uh Derek I know
I've talked so much and I know you have
some stuff you want to tell us so please
please indulge the people
I do while you're enjoying the content
provided uh we are always encouraging
that if you want to support black voices
in gaming the best way to do it is to
help head to our tiltify that's your
chance to donate and help support the
developers who are being accelerated
through programs like these
also we have some merch we're not
wearing the merch right now listen we
wanted to even mine's in the wash and
then and Derek says I don't know where
Dex is I think his is on his son
somewhere and they either but listen we
have merch so you know you want to wear
black voices and have you seen our logo
have you seen the design what are you
waiting for make sure that you go check
out our merch because it's absolutely
incredible and if you forget don't worry
we'll remind you again later in the show
to go check it out so uh yeah Derek what
else do we have for the people
lastly you know you need to follow us on
social media so remember to check out
black voices and gaming on Twitter
that's bvig BVI gaming as well as black
voices and Gaming's YouTube channel and
Instagram
that's right there's no excuse guys
we're on all the best social media
platforms so make sure you check us out
now with all that being said I know we
just threw a lot of information at you
all important though but I know what you
really came here to do is to get some
gaming and and to listen to some people
talk about how they've created these
amazing builds so
I'm going to introduce our first guest
listen guys I'm super excited about
introducing our first guest he's he's
amazing
um incredible and he has the dopest
sweater not that I saw him before but we
are going to be bringing up Jace will
share with his game little hellions and
before we get into it we're going to
show you the trailer get ready y'all
it's it's a wrong time
thank you
oh I know
[Music]
little hellions oh my God that just
totally reminds me of like when I used
to sit and do coach couch co-op with my
little brother and like play all these
games and the music oh I think I said it
before but like it it gives me the Vibes
of like when I was sitting there
watching uh Transformers the animated
movie for the first time like the music
is so jumping in this and listen I'm
super excited to get on Jace but first
before we before we bring on Jay
Starrett what did you think about the
trailer and what do you think about the
game this is bringing out the the metal
lover in me so while the trailer was
going I was just over here like air
guitaring and rocking out I'm excited
for little hellions so like Bring it on
Bring Jason here so we can learn more
about this game and I can watch y'all
play
oh
do you in the building I'm in the
building I'm in the house I'm here hello
hi
welcome welcome huge shout out to your
sweater by the way we love we love it
like the whole the whole vibe you've got
going but Jace we just saw the trailer
absolutely incredible can you tell our
viewers a little bit more about you and
your journey and kind of what influenced
you to make little hellions
oh my gosh
um yeah no I'm uh I'm Jace I've been
working on little hellions since 2015
which is a really really long time for a
person to be working on a video game
um I'm a solo developer so I basically
learned how to be a game developer over
that period of time
um and yeah I started I started it like
I said 2015 it was a global game Jam
game
and the the uh the uh what's it uh theme
for that jam was what do we do now
so the core idea of the game uh both
mechanically and aesthetically comes
from that like the game is about zipping
around the screen and being anywhere on
the screen any one moment what do you do
now and then it's also about the
underworld you're in the Underworld now
Eternal damnation what do you do now you
probably chill out and eat pizza
probably
listen I I love pizza so I would
probably be doing that if they allowed
us to do that in the Underworld
absolutely
but um you know what Chase one of the
things that we did talk about with your
game is that it is Co-op right so like
if you have a friend and it's you guys
and you're like sitting there you can
play it together with your friend right
beside you and I definitely miss that
because I feel like a lot of games don't
do that anymore so we're gonna jump into
the game and Jace is going to come in
the game with me and play it with me and
listen guys I know I talk a lot of smack
about how great I am at games and how
I'm like the absolute Pro
but Jace is definitely going to put me
to shame but to be fair he's the
developer so okay if it was anybody else
I would be amazing at this game but
while I'm getting all set up and we're
picking our characters I'm gonna throw
it over to Derek so he can ask you some
more questions
yes yes uh I I want to know more about
little Hellion specifically the art
direction that we saw in that trailer
can you tell us more about what inspired
uh you know the look and feel of this
game
yeah um
I mean when I first started
working on the like in that game Jam for
instance I am
okay I'm just gonna get out of the menu
here I um basically just had a character
like uh Lucy the little red character
there uh she was the first character
that I thought of for the game and then
I was like okay what would be the world
of a game that would support this
character and then the whole game kind
of arose from that where Lucy came from
was like you know a bunch of
Inspirations like um
I think I was kind of into like what was
that Series this Disgaea was kind of
into that at the time
um I've always had like a uh from a
distance fascination with the Guilty
Gear franchise so like kind of heavy
metal kind of like meets anime kind of
thing
um and then the rest of it was just like
I like Sonic or at least
I have a I have a um relationship with
the Sonic race
so a lot of the Aesthetics kind of are
drawn from like Sega era stuff yeah it's
kind of all over
good no I think it's I think it's
breathing those Aesthetics yeah
like we're not even in the game he's
like kicking my butt all right I'm I'm
just like running around how the game
works huh yes yes let's do that yeah uh
before we get too far in here so basic
uh so this is like the lobby right and
so what you can do is um bill hollions
is a fighting game it's like a party
fighting game
um but the core conceit is that you
can't um attack at all there's no way to
actually fight so what you can do is you
can throw this hook out and grab your
opponents so
your goal then is there's a bunch of
traps in the levels and you want to
throw your opponents into the Trap so I
would like say grab Lucy and chuck her
into the Trap it's got like a lot of
like Nuance to how the hook works like
for instance if I'm close to Lucy I'll
barely throw her whereas if I'm far away
I like catapult her
um and then there's kind of a rock paper
scissors mechanic on top of that where
you have this Shield so if you try to
use your Hook when your Shield is up
you'll get buried like that and there's
a bunch of like little nuances but
there's very few actual core mechanics
like that's pretty much it but how you
use those those tools is very um there's
a lot to learn you know
and it's got a weird menu system as
you've noticed yeah I was like I'm just
like jumping around and stuff you can
swap with the person who's controlling
the menu and be a little Goblin so
that's like what what that whole thing
is
um yeah
including gameplay in the game menu is
something that we don't often see done
so shout outs to tossing that in there
we never would have started if you left
it up to me
the whole time
I uh I really need to make a good
tutorial because people there there is
it is a weird game to pick up because
you're like well how do I fight I can't
punch
you know
um so like here we're um the trap in
this level is this the lava pit really
straightforward and you uh just want to
throw someone into the lava
by themselves
no I really love like okay so can we
talk a little bit about the aesthetic
and the Arts you've been working on this
since 2015. is this all you like the art
the characters like give us the lowdown
um yeah so
um
yeah I've done everything that's why
it's taking so long the only thing that
it's easier to say what I haven't done
so what I haven't done is the music the
music is uh licensed from Striker and uh
TWRP
and um it's got a pretty full soundtrack
and then um some of the background art
um not all of it for instance this
background I did but some of the
background art is um I work with this
guy for and we go back and forth on but
other than that like all the character
animation all the programming all of the
level geometry
you know everything uh game design it's
it's all me and that's why it's taking
so long of course I mean it looks really
good though like it looks so good the
the color the character I really like
the character design that's like super
cute well one of the things I noticed is
like there are pieces of candy falling
from the sky and I I love myself some
candy but like what what what importance
does that have in the actual game
so the cat the candy is um imagine like
Smash Bros Meats
um Mario Kart I guess for the candy so
it's like they're items but you'll get a
random item depending on the category of
candy you eat so the pink candies are
like attack offensive items
the green candies are defensive items
and the yellow candies are like special
items
the level wall you can you can walk to
one side of the wall and you'll come out
the other side of the yeah yeah
oh cool
so on this level you have this big death
wall that moves around and you can just
stand on these buttons to move the wall
around so a lot of the levels traps are
also interactive you you can um
you can um
oh my gosh I'm like right on the edge
there
you can you can actually control the
Trap as well as
um
as well as like yeah utilize it right oh
okay I see that yeah so
um I I find when people ask like okay
what kind of fighting game is this like
all the characters play the same there's
not um
there's not um like you know unique
abilities for each character so when it
comes to matchups you're almost like
learning how to play each level more
than you are each character right
right yeah yeah you know speaking of
that could you tell us more about the
levels like what uh what other traps or
stages or players are going to be
expecting to uh confront with
yeah
um well there's there's four worlds in
the game and each world has about six
levels I'd like to add more post launch
when that when that happens but um you
know as of now that's where it's at and
um yeah each world is themed around you
know like a series of traps so the first
one is shot in Florida that's like the
city of the underworld it's kind of like
your basic levels that have just kind of
help you understand how to play the game
like lava and
um
uh bomb pigs which is like the mascot of
the game he's he's my son
and then uh there's the the Boneyard
which is like a big scrap yard of Bones
we actually just saw that all the traps
in that that series of levels are about
kind of like movement and and big
machines that move you around
um
here here's a good one as an example
uh and then there's stabiland which
isn't
I'm a terrible smash so
um
I just spend half the game watching
everybody else play because I'm dead
so hellions kind of lets you keep
playing even if you're not particularly
good at the game and um
I think the exciting part of that is for
um you know
like uh
kind of advanced players that's actually
like kind of a good thing too because
the intensity of the match is always at
maximum because there's always four
people around even when they're dead
right
I love that and I love the fact that
you've actually thought about that and
implemented that into your game because
nobody likes like dying and then just
having to sit there and not be able to
join in on the fun so that's really
really cool we're actually rounding up
at the end of our time but before we go
if anybody wants to find out more about
you and your game can you drop your
socials where can we find out more about
you
yeah um the best one is probably my
twitch I stream every Monday and Friday
uh Game Dev so like if you want to uh
see how the game is made
um
how the sausage is made etc etc uh you
can you can see that that's uh twitch.tv
slash uh onion professor
and then I'm on Twitter but you know
the trash fire that is Twitter
um but uh I'm also on there at Professor
onion so it's it's the flip around
version of it
um but yeah those are my primary ones
well Jay thank you for taking some time
to come on and show us little hellions
and you know not pulverizing me too much
in the game I appreciate that I cannot
wait to pick it up guys if you liked
what you saw make sure you go over to
steam and wishlist it it means so much
to the devs and so much to the community
and yeah Jace thanks again uh I'm
excited please tell me you're releasing
the soundtrack for this game because
it's dope yeah
you can actually play the game now it is
in Early Access too so if you want to
just play you can do that it's in real
early
accessible Early Access not like Early
Access so it's not done but you can play
it if you want
well you heard it here folks now you
have no excuse go get the game go check
it out and check it out and rock out
thank you again thank you we'll talk to
you soon
bye
wow so that was incredible
uh I I was I was getting you know like
the the schroeden proud of you know
watching y'all play and missing out on
some of it so
um maybe that's where some of the names
you know like sitting on the couch and
and experiencing other people play uh
really really thoughtful uh you know
Studio name and gameplay but
um we we're about to head over to Island
City and that's distraction machine
where we'll be talking with Latif Martin
about their game and so stick around
because we have more gameplay more talks
coming up coming at you next
can you play something
for their friends and family
[Music]
foreign
or lead us to ruin
[Music]
wow that was cool I'm so here for the
artwork and and what's coming together
for a distraction machine but let's
bring in Latif oh I'm sorry it does what
did you think about the trailer before
we before we bring our teeth
I got so excited I'm just like ready to
jump ready
no I thought it was really cool it seems
to be set in this to stop this kind of
dystopian world and we're seeing if
music is going to be enough to kind of
bring us out of like this chaos that's
happening this distraction machine so
I'm really excited to talk to Latif and
get to know more about kind of like the
journey and the story of distraction
machine so Latif are you with us
I am indeed
what's going on
great to be here nice to meet you yes
it's nice to meet you it's so good to
have you here uh you know could you tell
our viewers uh you know who you are and
a little bit about distraction machine
yeah so um I am a multi-disciplinary
artist best way to handle all my ADHD
um and the creative director of
miscipating in the studios I thought of
the company back in 2013 and we're a
multimedia company
um and this trash machine is a music
competition game where you create music
to uplift and Inspire your community
during a zombie apocalypse
um and actually the game is based on a
larger world it's based on a comic book
series that we publish I am the uh
writer and so co-writer and illustrator
of the comic it's called Zyle and the
comic takes place seven years after and
this traction machine is actually the
prequel so the comic book is already out
we've had copies we've sold them in
stores and whatnot conventions and
decide you know as a multimedia project
you don't want to tell the same story on
different platforms so we figured okay
zombie apocalypse seven years after
because most zombie stories happen at
the apocalypse we figured what is it
like when people grow up like what is it
like when kids grow up in that world in
like zombies Undead is their reality uh
and what how do we explore that and then
I wanted to tell the story of what
happens before the comic book series so
that's what we did the game
that's incredible
I was gonna say you know and I can't
wait to ask more questions about the art
Direction but uh you know as we jump
into the game I I I was gonna say it
feels like a moving comic book uh in
what we saw in the trailer and so yeah I
I just want to see y'all play I'm gonna
be here for for moral support and and to
see what we're gonna get into here
cool so yeah and I'll walk you through a
little bit because uh yeah it's it's you
know just obviously this is still a demo
so there's a lot of little things that
you you might not get right away because
the functionality isn't all there but
yeah
listen I'm just hyped that um our main
character right here is a woman and a
woman of color like absolutely love that
I want to see that in more games so I'm
really excited that you have that
um but yeah let me go ahead and go
through some of this uh script I was
gonna read it and like try to do voice
acting but I'm not going to give up oh
no I'm gonna do it it'd be great really
okay yeah
hahaha
all right so we have a small window to
distract them before too many catch our
scent
kalu threw a mobile machine together for
you doesn't have the bells and the
whistles of your setup in the lair but
it'll do
now get on the truck and Lead that
frenzy away
all right Sean we're ready yeah so that
was good
thank you very much what should I pick
first like wait what I barely know what
I'm doing which is me that is me so I
feel like that's the one I should go
with
um as I try to save people but just to
you know give everybody a look the other
options are what kind of Beats should I
use
um I will build a soundscape these rabid
ghouls cannot ignore that was that was
that was nice
yeah
no worries no no uh so you know in
throughout the game you have two to
three options uh to respond with and the
dialogue choices help guide uh your
journey there are four different endings
of the game so uh depending on what uh
you know answers you you reply with
it'll lead you down a certain path
um and the three different ways that you
can that you can play the game is either
of a more communal Vibe or more of a
survival Instinct or more of a fanatic
we're not going to tell you which uh
which dialogue choices are are rich but
for example Shawna is a community based
as you can see from her the logo right
inside her name it's the logo for
community and the idea is that you know
you're giving exchanging and it's an
infinite circle of giving and thinking
so that's what that symbol requires or
rather represents so uh but yeah I mean
go with whatever when you feel yeah I'm
gonna go with this one because like you
know having everybody depend on me I
it's a little scary
look we don't need a five-part magnum
opus just make as much noise as you can
that I can do
all right all right so okay okay what
should I play or I'll do you know what
I'm gonna I'm gonna go with I'll do my
best because I will
that's all I ask of anyone all right
Shawna
ask the fighter guarding the truck for
some input they know the feeder's better
than anyone
all right
long live the fighters
and she said uh yeah sure just go days
we're on the same page yeah all right
get going I'm going
okay so Ahoy who are you he how do you
say his name hidovar
so I'll tell you later well I can tell
you now
um just really quick haidovar is a
character that actually exists in the
comic book series like seven years after
the story and when we did the comic book
we did the crowdfunding campaign and
people depending on how much they they
gave became characters in the comic so
he would give people a character profile
for him to fill in what's your name with
your exchange and weaknesses with
weapons and this person came up with
this character called heidevar who is
basically a dude who exists as a viking
within the world and so I decided he's
such a cool character in the comics
let's see how we started out in the
world of distraction machine so super
cool oh that's dope yeah I love that
so like when you're when you're playing
this game and you start off do you go
through each character's dialogue that's
on the screen
yeah uh in this case for example like
you know when you uh when you when a
person has a request to help them on
their missions there's criteria and
there are different people that will
give you criteria so this is where we're
at now we're getting criteria from the
crew
all right so this is hydevar I'm guys
I'm not even gonna try to do a guy voice
all my Guy voices sound like stoned like
like Surfers or something I don't know I
can't really do very good ones
okay it's all good yeah yeah yeah you
know Cali life
um Ahoy who are you okay so I'm
um I'm running the music box thingy I'm
just passing through uh the temp Bard
and I am the one they call distractor
who are you I'm gonna go with the first
one
cards are good for nothing but Victory
songs
all right
um Shauna wants my help will
enough with your witless prattle Bard
dang these people are mean okay these
Unholy Abominations swarm to the sound
of a heartbeat so use drums okay that
makes sense that makes sense all right
so next I would click on you're talking
about yeah
okay she has nothing to say she is not
interested she's that tall she's that
that strong mysterious type character
that you see in the anime she really had
nothing to say okay word
um Bomani
okay
you've got some big beats to fill I hope
you're up to oh I hope you're up to the
ask
or task I didn't say yes
yeah yeah
I'll give it everything I've got
that might not be good enough wow the
pessimism I'm gonna do my best
zombie apocalypse world you know comes
with a lot of pessimism you might be the
I would think so Drop in the Ocean right
now I don't even know what I would do in
a zombie apocalypse World make music
maybe also we'll give you a little
contact also just quickly leave you the
context so you're you're the newcomer
you're coming in as the new instructor
these their distractor sacrificed their
life to save you so basically you're
coming in and use a tractor like okay
who are you I don't think you can do the
job so everyone's like okay dude or or
or you know anything that makes sense
yeah especially if the guy they they
knew before like like you know sacrifice
their lives for me and they're kind of
like
you know I could see that I could see
that feeling get hurt all right I bang
my chair rings together chain rings
together when hunting feeders
really gets them riled up use a
percussion like a Shaker in your music
box
okay all right so now after I've talked
to everyone what's the next step so now
you go to your music box you go to the
the distractors layer so the the music
box icon is the one to the right
to the far right yeah this one right
here okay the the Diamond this one
yeah go down and go to the right I see
it yeah okay yeah
so now you're on the trunk and so now
you see you have your criteria you have
three criteria to fulfill you've got
your your music box which is has four
spaces in it you have different music
boxes throughout the game different
sizes different types of uh different
shapes and you have your inventory of
instruments on the side here so
basically at this point now it's about
filling up your music box with
instruments
okay so I know someone said something
about drums I'm okay I'm just gonna I'm
gonna pull some stuff in um put that in
baller and
this
and can you use like two of the same or
is it better to use like as many
different right okay it might be yeah
you could um but it might be good idea
so right now you wanna you wanna you
know uh brahmani suggested using a
percussion instrument so I would say
taking out you can take out the one of
the horn Gardens
okay drag it off and then you can uh and
you can go to the menu here and go up
and down and just the button the button
here up top
yeah yeah so the one just below right
there yeah so we're gonna go down and
you're going down to the oat Shaker down
there so you can grab that oh so that
would be because it's literally my
breakfast that's a that's a can of Oats
that I took and I shook and I sampled uh
for the game all these instruments
yeah so all these instruments are based
on instruments I've built uh or or I've
sampled uh in the studio
which is really really cool and I think
we're gonna like talk about that a
little bit because you have some in your
background but all right let's make our
first beat so we don't get eaten because
that's what I'm oh yeah
you're not quite finished because okay
um everything has to be connected with
chains that lead to the crank the crank
is the heart of the music box so you're
gonna go down to your menu menu you're
gonna go out first to your uh batons
your noise makers
is the second button
that one there there we go
yeah she's gonna grab one of the
noisemakers I suggest either Cali's
Mallet actually moko's brain piercer
would be good as well the one on the
bottom
yeah each of the noise makers fit in the
nodes the nodes are the spots uh like at
the corners of the frames but as you can
see the logo you see the logo here
matches the the logo there so you want
to drag it where you see the noise maker
logo icon on the music box so you see
there's four of them there it's four
like kind of red circles that are yes
yeah perfect there we go cool so now
that's the only instrument that needs a
noise maker next you gotta
connect them over chains and the cranks
you want to go down to the drivers on
the menu
the drivers the third button got it
and the Crunch
and grab the print okay so I can put the
crank anywhere so I can put it here and
we're good yeah oh yeah I would suggest
putting it in the middle because that
way everything can reach it
so now you're going to connect
everything with chains you're going to
drag the chain onto an instrument and
then drag it to the crank
there you go okay and so right here yeah
you can drag it there
nice I'm gonna put another one over here
right nope that's good you got us there
just drag it oh okay it's kind of
everything so just yeah just go yeah
just drag it right from there to the to
the crank oh you know why because that
is not that was another thing that's why
okay you can still drag it because it's
there so you can just drag it from the
middle of that wheel to the crank
there you go there we go so now
everything's connected you can see in
the corner at the criteria all your
criteria is fulfilled you could submit
requests uh you can write something's
requests uh but you can also
work on some music so for now you can do
a little preview you can grab the crank
and spin it counterclockwise
the other way around
yeah and then you can handle preview how
it sounds
you can just let go
no word oh that's kind of dope
yeah yeah
the center button up top which is the
composer we're going to open up the
composer each instrument has its own uh
um um
uh um sorry each instrument has its own
default Loop and it also has its own
Loop Library so now you have the play
sheets each instrument has its own sheet
of music so um the bar here you see the
bar that kind of Curves at the top you
can drag your mouse along up and down
the bar
right the bar that's vertical like the
silver bar here yeah
on the bar itself right yeah I'm walking
down oh okay oh okay okay I see that
what you just did by mistake which is
actually really cool is you uh you just
you hit the trash can icon and you
deleted all the notes that are on the
sheet but you can add your own notes
that's normal it's perfect you can add
your address
okay uh break it down a bit drag drag
the sheets down a bit so you can see the
title click on oat Shaker the word
itself
for example the next one up that has a
bunch of loops right so you can add your
own these are already pre oh okay okay
actually the goal for us is like no
matter what your music proficiency you
should be able to create music that's
fun and easily so just a bunch of loop
you can mix and match you can write your
own music
um and and yeah so there's a bunch of
different types of styles of music
um I have I have a background of music
so
um you know and and I've jumped from
scene from Hip Hop to to the the
industrial Knights um I've gone to like
you know Raves and whatnot so there's a
lot of different types of Dramas and
music in there
um to play with so yeah yeah yeah oh I
wish we I wish we had more time to be
able to experience distraction machine
because it seems like that there's so
many excellent parts that need you know
their own window of of learning curve
and or sorry not learning curve but like
time to explain so that
um so people can really dig in because
uh it sounds like just on the the
information that you've given us so far
if there's really a lot of expansive
gameplay and I'm excited to be able to
hear it all come together
um yeah but we're unfortunately out of
time but before uh before we're out of
here for those of you for those who are
out there and want to learn more and
want to dig into those details where can
you tell people to find out more about
distraction machine uh and and how can
they get the game
cool yeah well uh our steam page is up
so if you like it please wish list
um but yeah we're looking to release our
games sometime in the summer uh and yeah
pretty much that's it and there's two
sides of the game there's Chronicle mode
which we're playing right now on this
conductor mode with just endless Music
Creation so that's that's the mode of
the game where you can just make music
and you can save it as a file as a sound
file or you can actually save the song
send it to your friend it was a copy of
the game they can open it up and remix
your song so it's really about sharing
your Truth uh yeah if you want to create
a a we want to create a community of
distractors around the world and I'd
love to hear what people are coming up
with
um it's funny I don't know if you saw it
but the the trailer for The Tetris movie
came out about how Tetris is created and
just recently I did a remix of a Tetra
song with the game uh so I'll send you
guys a link about that and you can do it
yeah please do that's yeah incredible
yeah yeah just to say real quickly uh
where you were at the game at that point
you could have hit submit request and
when you hit submit request you see how
the music affects the mission so what
would happen you would receive your
quest the music plays and it the scene
plays out and whether if you actually
did
yeah I actually did hit submit and
Shauna said not too shabby so I'm I'm
kind of proud about work we did here
today yeah good so yeah you can either
help or harm the community based on how
well you follow criteria that time you
save the day Shawna said not too shabby
everyone's saved if you didn't find it
if you didn't follow the criteria people
would have died and would have been your
fault
wow
so much to dig into I'm so excited here
first yeah I want to thank you again for
being able to join us today
um it's been exciting to get to see bits
and pieces of distraction machine and
I'm just looking forward to more
thank you yeah I can't wait for people
to play it thanks so much for your time
thank you
all right ciao
wow so I mean I'm enjoying that Dez you
got to dig into it and I hope it I hope
it drew you in but you know for those of
you are out there if you too are
enjoying what you're seeing so far
please consider supporting the
developers through tiltify donations to
Black voices in gaming go toward our
mission to helping game studios and game
Studio entrepreneurs succeed
and so while you're at it you know
making those donations supporting the
developers you can support them another
way
it's the steam page go to the black
voices and game Steam page to wishlist
any of the games on today's show as well
as many more we encourage you to do it
right now
yeah go wish list it means so much to
them but you know what we're going to
keep it going we're going to keep it
going because we have our third guest
who is coming up the voice over finicia
finiciado it's a finishing up finishing
oil I it doesn't matter she's amazing
she's incredible Queen noveen who is
voicing our girl Layla in redfall is up
next let's check out the trailer
[Music]
you
you I know
I know
yes
foreign
[Music]
well it's red
play it day one with Game Pass
yo
I remember when that first aired last
year when I saw it and I got super
excited because I saw a black female
character and she was just bad to the
bone like she was incredible
and so
Derek tell just tell me how do you feel
about redfall like are you ready for it
uh uh yes and no look I am a big fan of
immersive Sims I love the stuff that
Arcane puts out specifically uh to pray
and Dishonored are huge for me and so
when when red Falls trailer came out it
was the same Vibes and we we got to see
the character on screen Layla's amazing
hair like everything everything's
perfect I'm so excited for it
I mean like you took the words right out
of my mouth but listen what's even more
exciting and what's even more incredible
is that we have Queen novene the
wonderful the amazing incredibly
talented voice over artist who is Layla
in red fall queen Naveen are you in the
building are you here with us hello yes
I am thank you guys so much for having
me
oh thank God it's a pleasure thank you
for yeah yeah I was about to say the
same thing thank you for taking time out
of your schedule to be a part of this
and help us celebrate Black voices and
gaming and you know what it kind of like
fits right we're talking about black
voices in gaming and you're a voice
actress and you're you're doing your
thing out there and you're basically
holding up this whole representation
that we really want to see like the
diversifying of the game industry so
let's kind of delve into the story of
you like have you always wanted to be a
voice actress haven't you how did you
get into this
actually I didn't even really know what
voiceover was when I was younger um I
started in theater in Live Theater and
performing in plays and stuff and uh did
that all the way up until college and
but throughout my life growing up
everyone's like you have such a great
voice you should try voiceover so where
I took acting classes they had a
voiceover class finally decided to jump
into that took that for about a year and
after that I signed with a voiceover
agent and my career kind of just took
off so voiceover kind of snuck into my
life but I really like what I've done so
far and where I've ended up with voice
over so
um yeah it's kind of like a natural
talent I didn't know I had and I'm using
it to the best of my ability
that's what's up and you do have a great
voice like you have a wonderful speaking
voice it's very like melodic I'm pretty
sure that's a word thank you yeah very
melodic and I love it
but like I don't want to ask all the
questions because I will like I could
talk for hours to you just about
everything but I know Derek has some
questions too so we're gonna go back and
forth so I'm gonna throw it to Derek
Derek cool what what's up what do you
want to ask I mean uh there's where do I
begin you know you you sure right about
uh about you know how you jumped into
voice acting
um you know let's talk about Layla you
know that that's what that's what brings
you here and so what was it like to uh
to play as Layla uh was this your first
video game character role uh but it but
you know give us the details
yeah so I've done a few video games
before this and stepping into Layla
actually was not that hard I pretty much
easily related to her I mean one she's a
black female I'm a black female
um we both have like that poofy kind of
curly hair same kind of facial features
and just the personality and who she is
she's very sassy she's smart
um she's got student debt I got student
debt so like it was so easy to jump into
her and kind of just uh bring her to
life and I really enjoyed
um recording her lines in the studio and
we always had a lot of fun so I'm really
excited for this to come out and to
share Layla with the world
from that was uh was that you are Layla
and Layla is you so
um yeah yeah pretty much I love the part
about uh student debt because I was like
damn we we're still worrying about
student debt with the vampires or
anything which seems very very realistic
honestly they made her very realistic
yes
I was like good job good job
right
but um not only that like I just want to
give a shout out really quick to level
one gaming because they're the ones who
kind of put us in touch with you and
like I know when I sat back and I I
watched that um intro like that whole
interview I was like dang how'd they get
her on there that's so incredible and so
when we were doing ours and we wanted to
diversify it up we were like we have to
I have to have her and when Derek
messaged me I was like I'm gonna see
what I can do I have the perfect person
and so it was just
listen we were so excited when you were
like yeah yeah I'll come on and this is
something that I want to be a part of
and like just thank you so much you know
what I mean oh we'll see yeah
yeah you know it's absolutely incredible
and
um before I throw it back to Derek I
know you've done voice over work but I
know you're also doing other things and
I think that's really important for like
our viewers and our and our listeners to
see that like it's not just voice over
like you use your voice in so many
different ways and you recently just did
something that was really incredible
that I saw on Twitter so can you tell us
a little bit about that because that was
really cool Kelly Clarkson hint hint
yes so uh first of all yes shout out to
um Level One gaming they are amazing and
thank you so much for them putting me
and uh you in touch with me I'm so happy
to be here uh but yeah I got to be the
live announcer for the NFL honors so
basically that's like the Oscars for the
NFL that they have every year and it was
held in Phoenix Arizona this year
um I headed out there I was able to walk
the red carpet I was there for three
days of rehearsals
um got to meet Kelly Clarkson herself
and she's most down to earth
um humble person like celebrity that
I've ever met I mean she just hugged me
came right up to me she was like oh my
gosh I've never met someone as short as
you you're short as my mama
[Laughter]
yes Kelly
but she was amazing voicing the NFL
honors was amazing um I'm not
so much into football uh my fiance had
the best time of his life because he
knows
I was like this is really for him you're
welcome
um but yeah I had a great time doing it
it was such a cool experience because I
haven't done an award show where it's
based on Just Sports like football so um
that was definitely something cool that
I got to add to my books um but it was
an amazing experience and I'm glad I got
to do it
exciting
I know when I saw it I was like I you
did a little clip and I was like she's
so excited when she's doing like the
energy that you put into it is just like
absolutely incredible and I know like
that's something that you have to keep
up even if you're not feeling like
you're super energetic and I think one
of the questions that um Derek uh had
had put down was um could you talk a
little bit about the challenges that
come with a role like doing voice over
work and things like that yep so uh for
voice over specifically let's say you do
like like live announcing live
announcing there's really no room for
mistakes at all so you have to be on top
of it you have to be able to take take
change on the spot you have to be brave
and courageous because your live
announcing a show that millions of
people are seeing at the same time and
you have to be on the ball so it's very
nerve-wracking for a lot of people but
for me specifically it's thrilling I I
thrive in the chaos I love it so much
um so it's awesome for me but when it
comes to like animation or video games
say
um you have room for mistake you have
rooms for uh to do new takes or figure
out a new way to say this line or that
line so you have room for imagination
basically
um so the room is basically yours you
can play around have fun with the
character
um so uh I want to make sure I got your
question right what are the challenges
you had said no that was that was great
okay but like
that was really good because I'm
thinking like yeah if you if you're
doing something live I know when we did
the live black voices in gaming I was so
nervous because there's no like hey
let's do that take again right like it's
just if you flub up you flub up and you
just keep going but like part of it is
like not making a big deal that you made
a mistake because usually people don't
catch on to those mistakes it's only
it's in your head how big it is so yeah
so you have to not get worked up in
yourself exactly you have to just be
able to improv on the spot if you make a
mistake
pull right back to it like so taking
improv classes as well definitely helps
with that
yeah these are some good tips dear what
do you have no speaking of tips uh you
know what uh for those who are out there
listening to this interview and and
feeling like a video game or voiceover
or cartoon voice over any other aspect
of it is something that I want to jump
into what would you say to somebody who
is aspiring to start a career as a
voiceover artist
so this may sound like a generic basic
answer but it's very very important you
have to take classes you have to know
what you're doing before you jump into a
career that you don't really know much
about so taking classes basically will
teach you the basics of Voice or the
terminology techniques how it all works
you have to really know what you're
doing and that is the first step in
getting into voiceover and from there
they can help you create a demo they can
help you submit to different agencies so
I think taking classes is definitely
um an important step into getting into
the voice over World
um you have to also be able to network
with people because Hollywood is all
about networking so you have to get
yourself out there you have to submit
you have to go to these workshops and
these classes and these events and
conferences I mean if you want to be in
voiced over you have to be all in it
there's no halfway or I'll try a little
bit and see where it goes you have to be
all in it so it definitely takes time
energy money
sleep but take care of yourself and if
you want to do it go for it
yeah I love that I hope I hope you guys
are listening like it's gonna take some
work like this is not something that's
gonna happen like overnight and I think
a lot of people think
um just because they have a microphone
and and everything they can just like go
for it but like um I love the fact that
you also brought up networking because a
lot of people will talk about you got to
go to school you got to take classes but
not only that you have to network
um and networking is I think the seed of
networking starts with the people that
you're in class with right like you just
never know who's gonna meet someone else
like for example
um everybody knows Justin because Justin
is the one who kind of helped put this
together but I met Justin in college I
used to like hang out at his place and
I've definitely crashed on his couch
before and like to see how far he's come
to putting something like this together
it really is
do not look at everybody as your
competition that is what I'm gonna say
yes please learn how to network that is
so important yeah
yes exactly I agree
I agree I'm so glad that we highlighted
you know how to
um some of these important values in
getting involved you know certainly the
role of a voice over Artist as much as
other careers relating to and not when
it comes to gaming should not be
minimized to just uh hop in and then
you're done and suddenly monies uh it
takes a lot of effort in planning
speaking of planning do you have any
goals for the future especially when it
comes to being a voiceover artist does
it does it involve more games does it
transcend to or not transcend but
transition into cartoons or animation
what else is on deck for you
well I have two tools that um I've
always wanted in voiceover so the first
one is to be on the Disney Channel I
love Disney everything Disney I would
love to voice one of their animated
shows or Pixar as well Pixar and Disney
being one of their animated movies
I would love that I mean this is my only
tattoo so yes it has to be Disney love
everything Disney so that is has been my
goal since day one so definitely still
working towards that and working on that
and hoping to make that a reality very
soon
um and then my second goal is live
announcing continue live announcing I
told myself I wanted to live announce an
award show at least once a year to have
at least one show to do once a year and
lately I've been very
um
thankful and grateful to be able to get
more than that so I definitely want to
stay on that pad stay on that road again
like I said I thrive in the chaos so I
want to keep doing live announcing shows
and to try my try my skill at different
kinds of shows as well just like sports
was my first one at the NFL would love
to do more so yeah
I think that's incredible I'm excited
yeah and I know you're going to reach
those goals absolutely I'm sorry Derek I
keep cutting you off my bed good it's
all good we're all excited no you
mentioned the Disney Channel like I
can't uh I can't leave this conversation
without at least chiming into that old
you're watching the Disney Channel
moment where they have the celebrity and
like Trace
yes I always practice it I was like I'm
gonna get this mouse right I got it guys
that would go we give you that
motivation as we as we uh you know
conclude our conversation for today's
that's gonna be what you're what you'll
do with Disney
I'm ready for that
um as you were talking this is super
random but like you gave me like I love
Cree Summers I know she's done a lot of
the the black voices and ethnic voices
but like you gave me Maxine vibes from
uh Batman Beyond like just listening to
you talk I was just like I could totally
see if they did a reboot I've gotten
that before yeah yes and I wanted to be
here when I grew up that that's not
happened yet but um yeah no I could
totally see you doing that but um again
you know what I just
I'm just sewing all of all you've done
and I don't know how many people tell
you that they're proud of you who you've
just met for the first time but I am
very very proud of you and what you've
accomplished because I feel like so many
little girls uh like myself and and like
you we grew up and and we wanted to be
these things and we wanted to see these
things and we're out here doing it and
that takes a lot of work it takes a lot
of dedication so uh from one creative to
another I appreciate all that you've
done and again I just want to thank you
for taking time out of your schedule to
come on and talk to us about your
journey and about Layla and guys don't
don't sleep on this game definitely get
the game even if you're terrible at it
like just get it and and support and
just be a part of it I mean like I know
I'm terrible at first person shooters
but you already know which character I'm
playing so
same though
yes well thank you guys so much of
course
um for having me uh I'm just glad I can
be someone a woman of color especially
to open those doors and pave the way in
being inspiration for uh younger kids
and anyone else who wants to get into
this industry that you can do it too we
can break these barriers we can be leads
in video games we can live announce
award shows we can do anything so I'm
here to help I'm glad I can pave the way
for all of you guys so let's get this
no that's what's up Elena if anybody
wanted to find out any information about
you or if they wanted to continue to
follow your journey where could they
find you
anyone can find me on Instagram Tick
Tock Facebook Twitter at Queen novene
I'm here and I'm available
um you can also head to my website at
www.queenovine.com there I have a lot of
information on my back story and my
journey and what I'm up to coming up
soon and as well as voiceover tips if
you're looking to get into the industry
I have a lot of tips on my website so
hopefully that can help you guys and uh
yeah let's chat
awesome she didn't notice that I called
her Layla that's because she's the same
character inside and out so she just
went right
I was like is she gonna notice
oh
yes thank you so much thank you thank
you for coming on we really appreciate
it and guys please go check out if
you're if you're interested in becoming
one well becoming a voice over actress
like that's my new goal now make sure
you check out her website and follow her
journey she's incredible and um yeah we
can't thank you enough for coming on
with us today
thank you guys so much thank you take
care
that was a great interview like I'm
listen I'm so like just touched like I
feel inspired
right right so I I heard tidbits you
said you you now have a a branching uh
uh uh path in into voiceover is when are
we starting when are you jumping in uh
voice over for a distraction machine and
and clearly this is just the beginning
of it that is true it's just you know
been like right after we wrap up the
show like I'm I'm gonna I'm just gonna
like find some classes I'm gonna do I
really think I'm gonna try and do it I
think it'd be really fun but guys before
we move on to our next guest don't
forget to check out our theme store and
wish list some of the games that you've
seen today and that you've seen on our
past shows honestly it helps our
developers so much it lets steam know
that their games are up and coming and
popping and people really want to see
them and so you know that just creates a
a better future for all the algorithms
and all of our games because they're all
dope they're all amazing
but uh yeah I'm gonna throw it over to
Derek so he can introduce our next guest
guys I'm like I'm just like really hyped
off of coming off of that interview I'm
sorry like you know just roll with it
it's cool
it's all good next up we have a couple
trailers to share with you first first a
new update from new Challengers tactical
beat em up treachery and Beatdown City
scheduled to launch on Xbox on April
27th the ultra remix update packs a
punch with three times the amount of
content free to existing owners on PC
and Nintendo switch starting in April
this includes but is not limited to
eight new maps over 80 new enemies from
fascist cops and preppy sucks preppy
cyclists to affluent punks and even
ninja Terrace you try saying that list
over and over all new attack moves
defense gameplay mechanics and more
music
yeah I was gonna say something about
that I was like that was that was a
tongue twister I don't know if I could
say it so I think you did a really good
job honestly but um next up is ukungu
and listen I had to look that up because
I did not want to say it wrong I
actually had the whole team look it up
because we wanted to make sure we got it
right but if Congo is a fantasy
Adventure indie game currently in
development this game is a fast-paced
action RPG spotlighting with blacks and
Africans taking on lead roles in the
story the trailer coming up will give
you a peek at a number of different
enemy encounters beautifully rendered
environments multiple combat Styles and
a brief glance into the deep floor
surrounding the group of Truth Seekers
now get ready to check out these
trailers and stay tuned for more info on
our bundles tiltify and our socials
[Music]
to the next episode
Boulevard
[Music]
foreign
we don't have time not to fight back
[Music]
breathe go let a man grow let the land
flow black get my Kinfolk or the gold
and a set for info leave no sleep at a
snap I could sleep in a tree while I'm
still in the attack cause we here now
but you bout to get a show when we throw
down ghosts getting close let me slow
down whoa gone looking for a throw now
to be gone if it's water in sight in the
song now
[Music]
foreign
before we get to our next guest I gotta
invite you to take a moment to look at
the bvig merch you can stop at
themixmerch.com right now to check out
what we have now destiny who do we have
coming up next
well I'm glad you did that and remember
guys I told you we were going to bring
this up again so go check out that merch
but next Our Guest is well we actually
have two of them and they're from on the
Peril of parrots welcoming to the stage
Chase bethia and Glenn Henry
oh
[Music]
foreign
yo so I was vibing on the tunes of that
trailer until the spooky moment came in
and took me out I need to know more
about it that's how did you feel I
wasn't ready I wasn't ready for that
like I was definitely vibing like the
music is so chill and relaxing and then
it was like somebody might be watching
you and I listen I wasn't prepared I
wasn't prepared to deal with that but I
want to know where this is going
yes thankfully we have Chase bethia and
Glenn Henry with us here today to talk
about on the Peril of Paris Chase Lynn
hello
hi how's it going
hey what's
what's glad you guys
you guys doing their thing in the gaming
industry so thank you thank you for
coming on and spending some time with us
thanks for having us
yes now if you could please and I'll
Glenn we'll start with you do you mind
sharing uh each of your roles on the
team
okay no problem uh I'm the principal
codo and artist behind the game
um so I'm making the puzzles and making
the things move up and down and Chase
when I go yes I am the composer in music
designer working along with Glenn to
make it a little bit more interactive
and dynamic with the long the puzzles
and keeping it chill as you have heard
yeah yeah interactive and dynamic you
say now this is a great segue to find
out what that means for our game uh and
as we're jumping in here I would love to
hear about on the Peril of parrots what
are we going to be getting into
oh
um well on the parallel of parrots other
than being a multiple to see
um is a puzzle narrative game right you
take control of an AI and you're being
run through all these tests as part of
this big shadowy experiment
so yeah
yeah
I I already messed up
foreign
somebody's watching you and they're
going to be judging these decisions
that's what's got me so nervous
I see all right yeah I already messed up
okay we're just gonna keep going like I
didn't mess up
um yeah
to be fair I'm not very good at these
puzzles but uh don't don't everybody
watch me play the game please
I was captivated I was captivated by the
puzzles because I'm I'm in the
background kind of like solving it as
well going like yeah go that way you're
doing great but also yes we need to know
more about the game we have uh two
talented individuals here to explain it
to us
um chase you talked about Dynamics and I
imagine that somewhat relates to the
music given your role on the team would
you care to expand on some of those
details
yeah sure so the focus of that the music
is going to serve is it for it to be as
as you're feeling stressful nice job Des
as you're feeling thank you
stressful in terms of gives me a second
sorry about that so as you're feeling
the stress of trying to solve the puzzle
in Glenn and I are working with a system
where is it you're gonna unlock
different layers of the musical
instruments as you continue through a
subset of
puzzles that you get through and
different game mechanics that I don't
want to spoil right now I'm going to be
helping to probably take over from there
and share more details on
yeah don't listen to me I'm trying to
trying to figure out which one if I go
that way and get stuck so I gotta go
left right
yeah yeah I already messed up it's
already over
all right
yo I was so close
okay guys we're gonna do it again all
right
um guys listen this is the most
nerve-wracking I've ever been like in
playing a game because everybody's like
just watching me like constantly like I
know because you've designed it you're
like she already messed up man like look
I know I already messed up
stop nobody watched
nobody's nope
Look Away over your eyes we will we will
stick to we'll stick to talking about
these mechanics uh you know to that
point Glenn what what else can you tell
us about uh about this game what sort of
challenges are players going to be
getting into
all right so the game itself is pretty
simple pretty straightforward
um you're supposed to find a good good
to go path for each of the puzzles all
right
um and what we have been trying to do is
kind of just build the old like
different pedals special towels
um you might have seen some in the
trailer that kind of flipped the script
on the challenge so some of them will do
things like the color that you you are
so he's kind of challenging you to
change how you navigate entire puzzle
some of them are like locks and keys
quickly but the idea is to kind of be
hit that sweet spot between um like
difficulty and Zen like kind of thing
and then that's one of the reasons why I
reached out to chase the kind of I've
worked with him on some previous
projects
and I have confidence you know bring my
vision to life which is this chill
experience a slightly Zen but at the
same time it's like the frustrating he
says
and yeah watching people play is like a
girl like the thing even though I
designed the puzzles
um
seeing people find these new Solutions
because even yeah even I don't want to
give too much of a hint but even wave
that there's solving it like this is
really interesting I am not trying
you're doing well
you're doing well it seems it appears to
be going well
no
no I already know I messed up now
let's see the cool thing about I think
what Glenn is talking about as well is
that
so everyone solves it a little bit
different
um we at least for me when I'm playing
Glenn design the puzzles
I discovered at least doing about three
run-throughs already of the entire game
thus far of the demo that there are at
least two ways to solve it at least that
I've discovered and so what I enjoy
seeing when people play and I think this
is for anything is you learn how they're
thinking and you're seeing them improve
as it goes along and so what we're
seeing here is the Improvement and
rather than some people who just fly
through it right away
and then that's all so nice
you don't know because okay let me tell
you like I feel like this is how I feel
like when I play like a a game that uh
you kind of have to play over and over
again I think like cuphead I'll give
that as an example like the first couple
of times I'm like oh I did pretty good
the more I play the more I get
frustrated the more I mess up so please
guys when you play this game don't look
at it as like like this is what's gonna
happen to you this is a flaw in my
personality
no
[Laughter]
speaking through this but go ahead
speaking of this this balance of of uh
Zen and frustration how did you consider
that when building a puzzle game and
yeah how did you iterate on on challenge
yeah I imagine uh the the difficulty
scale goes up as as you start to
accomplish more levels
so the idea is as you go as you progress
you unlock new channels and they add to
the challenge
um but like building an experience that
was
yes I knew you were gonna get that one
yeah
building on
uh wow I was so I was like very much
interested
[Laughter]
um but yeah
one of the tricks that we did was
actually build out like a daily demo
version of this
um where it was just a daily diagnostic
where built the levels we threw them up
and you can play like I love London we
just have that
um and we use that to kind of get
information on like the difficulty or
how people feel about the game overall
and they use that as a guide for the
puzzles and went into the well we are
going into the final game
um and yeah that's how we did it uh in
terms of gauging things it's really hard
at least for me I'm not sure if Jace can
Echo this but like like after you solve
a puzzle
um it's hard to rank it again after you
do it like it's just now in the back of
your head uh so if you play it a couple
times
it kind of just sticks so you lose the
ability to
um age it properly
so yeah that's one of the tricks we did
to kind of get feedback early feedback
and build and hydrate this
the thing that I find interesting is
like
I can already tell when I messed up like
immediately where like with most games
you don't know but like
most of the time even like if you see me
keep playing I'm like I knew already
messed up like if you go back and watch
this you'll see my facial expressions
and all the things you know what I mean
so um but like it is it is one of those
games that I feel like can get really
addictive to where it's like you're not
gonna let this game beat you and you
have to keep playing until you you get
through that's how at least that's how I
feel about it like
I'm just not gonna let it beat me but
it's gonna beat me like 32 times before
I like actually it's okay sorry it's no
big deal
I already messed up all right
it's really great now we have
um I I have to acknowledge the cool
juxtaposition between uh the art style
and the music
um you know starting with uh starting
with you Glenn could you tell us about
what inspired the the look of the game
and then Chase I would love to hear what
uh what led you to uh choosing say this
genre to go along with it
okay so in terms of the look
um
wow that's a long story but yeah um
so the game actually started as a game
Jam game in like 2018
um it was a global game Jam
um I was uh site organizer for all the
Jamaica um
it's funny though it was a simple
critical path possible and for the
longest time
um couldn't land on like a theme around
it felt like a solid game people like
the idea of it but like accompanying it
with a theme and something that you know
could really resonate with people was
hard so kind of just kept in my back
pocket and then
um stumbled this might be super nerdy so
apologies but it's almost across uh a
paper
um by Dr Timmy
uh no right oh I got this you got this
yes
[Laughter]
on the dangers of stochastic parents
which was okay AI and the
dangers of um or the concerns around
training AI large language models and
too large of a data set and now
that name stuck with me and the idea
stuck with me and I kind of just
Hercules in the back of my head to say
okay let's let's make this AI let's make
this kind of a
[Music]
um
retro futuristic Vibe right
um and yeah that's where this entire
screen the glow effects the neon colors
all of that came from just kind of
building on that over time I'm slowly
unsuring
excellent
as for the audio uh I'll leave that over
to chase like I I just gave him a theme
and he just works his magic
I got that one without messing up
let's go see yeah pretty excited look
I'm so into this game I'm not asking any
questions and I feel really bad so um
and I'm also not concentrating on what's
being asked so I don't want to ask the
same thing over and over again because
no you're doing great concentration but
um one of the things I I wanted to ask
like I know you talked a little bit uh
about the the aesthetic and that like
this was like one of those
um what is it called game jams am I
saying that right game jams and we've
seen so many games that like have
started out that way and have come like
full circle into like like this puts me
on the vibe of like when you play Tetris
or something like that like a game that
you play like over and over but like has
a a high replayable value to it was that
your goal when you first decided to like
go with this theme of game were you like
I want people to be able to play this
like over and over again just because of
the the challenge that I put in it
uh no that wasn't like no it wasn't the
thought
right there actually is an aspect of
liability around like
story aspects which I think you're gonna
hit on I've eaten like
oh okay
the challenge itself
was kind of incidental it's just because
of the systems we built up the jam and
um
how quickly we can turn off the puzzles
and the entire idea just kind of Lent
itself that like just turned around spin
up
um
like you can just build puzzles really
quickly I play them they test them yeah
it was easier for us to make a lot of
content versus you know prioritizing
replayability
yeah in this way that's actually pretty
smart yeah
uh there were some things that you're uh
you're about to share about some some of
the music aspects and I'm really
interested how that came together uh you
know with with the theme Here
yeah absolutely so Glenn gave me a theme
and he said hey working on this type of
game and
I would like Bossa Nova and I said what
and I lost I lost my mind because I grew
up with that music actually a lot in my
childhood and it's one of my favorite
genres and so too throughout the years
of working in the industry I've subtly
clipped Bossa Nova type of tracks in
different games that I've scored but to
do an entire soundtrack was
very exciting
a lot of pressure because there's
there's legends that I know of that I'm
I I listen to and that I know are the
the standards even of what that style is
and what everybody typically feels that
Vibe is and so being a video game
composer I always feel especially with
how I write that I don't always need to
push it a little bit above so that that
style for a little bit history is about
the late 60s early 70s of what
everyone's typically familiar with with
Antonio Carlos so beam or
Stan gets in Astrid Gilberto and a
couple others
and so I also am trying to
pay homage to that style but also bring
it into a little bit of this era to a
tiny bit so
I'm probably using some instruments that
typically wouldn't be in the
the genre to to be set but as long as
the texture is good and I'm I'm kind of
getting away with it and I'm very happy
and a lot of people seem to be enjoying
it and so that makes me very very happy
as well
Chase Glenn it has been a pleasure to
spend time with you today and learn
about on the Peril of parrots before
you're out of here could you please tell
everybody watching where they can find
this game
where where to get it
um well the game is on Steam right now
we're just coming up to the next best uh
so plug that in you can find it uh if
you want to find out more about the game
when it releases follow me on Sprint
wrench all right a Sprite like soda
wrench like the Tool uh okay
yep and if you want to find out more
about me I'm pretty active on Twitter
and it's at Chase with Thea and if the
soundtrack's actually on pre-order or
chase with Thea dogbankcamp.com so you
can tie in their wish list and check out
the pre-order if you're enjoying the
music outside of the game
awesome awesome
thanks for sharing that with us and we
will definitely be following you and
following more about the game and when
you said Sprite I got so thirsty like
legit definitely I just I was like geez
what I would love a Sprite right now but
thank you guys for taking some time out
of your day to come on and be a part of
black voices and gaming where we
continuously uplift black creators in
the gaming industry so yes thank you
thank you I loved your game I am going
to beat it
um as soon as we get off of here I'm
gonna go practice Yeah and then I'm
gonna like hit you up and tell you how
far I got so yeah
there you go
I love it
um you know you see now that you said
Sprite and and you brought up being
thirsty I have no doubts that every
other black audience member is feeling
the same Vibe I I got hit with it too
now that you put that context in the
frame but
getting the spin valuable time with
developers and learn from that learn
from them is incredible if you're
interested in supporting these
developers absolutely consider checking
out our black voices in gaming steam
page to wish list the titles and more uh
from from the ones that we've seen here
as well as others additionally if you
want to find another way to support our
developers consider donating to our
tiltify donations to Black voices in
gaming goes towards our mission to help
game developers succeed
and we are all
are all who want to succeed and put in
the work and like everybody who's been a
part of these shows from the past up
until now have done such an incredible
job we are so so proud of you here at
black voices and gaming but guys we're
not done we still have more to show next
up is super space club by the wonderful
and creative developer Graham read so
let's jump into it let's watch that
trailer
foreign
[Music]
sometimes
yo that was super space club by
developer Graham Reed listen I
absolutely loved it the music was so
chill and this is kind of like a Lo-Fi
arcade space shooter and I'm excited for
it I can't wait to get my hands on it
Derek what did you think
I'm right there with you I'm I'm vibing
with the music and I'm just looking
forward to playing it
well you know what
we have with us our special guest Graham
Graham are you there
yo what's good what's good thanks for
having me
welcome to Black voices and gaming I'm
so happy that you could come on the show
show us your game yes like I love that
kind of excitement so Graham can you
tell our guests a little bit well our
viewers a little bit more about you and
like what made you decide to make this
type of game and like what influenced
you
yeah of course so my name is Graham Reed
I'm from Kingston Jamaica and I
currently live in New York but I moved
up here
I don't know like in 2012 or so and it's
been horrible since
um but about the game
I don't know like I just really
have a passion for making games but it's
just me as a solo developer and so I
figured something in the vein of super
space Club in the van over asteroids
like Sarah Fox kind of Vibes or
something that I could actually fall off
so yeah this is how I ended up there
that's incredible especially since
you're a solo developer I couldn't even
I I can't I can't put two strings of um
what's it called when you're scripting
yeah script together so see I didn't see
I couldn't even do it so I'm always like
in awe of people who are like yeah I did
this game by myself but um I think we're
gonna jump right into the game listen
this is uh me trying to play first like
a shooter because I'm pretty terrible at
this so please just uh bear with me Anna
I'm gonna throw the mic over to my
wonderful co-host so he can ask you some
questions if I figure out how to not die
thank you you know we got you for the
moral support but while Dez is jumping
in
Graham you mentioned being a solo
developer and I would love to hear just
what was that Journey getting into game
development
yo the giant has been it's been a tricky
one
it's been really fun though like I can't
even like it's been really it's been
really fun
um I started with two other friends from
Jamaica
um back in college
and it went from me thinking that oh you
know gained up is only for these big
companies and Nintendos the sun is all
those companies too oh you can have
access to Unity and at that time use up
engine called Corona which funny enough
and yeah zero was four was made again
and it was sick and so since then I
downloaded Unity made the whole thing I
made like a World Cup hung game I call
it World Cup on so cheesy
and since then I was like all right cool
but I was gonna start making games
though because it went from me being an
avid gamer my whole life so no I can
actually be the one making the games and
giving everybody The Vibes experiences
so there's something to enjoy in their
lives you know
certainly it's been really hard though
because I've been
up until 2021 I've been doing it nights
and weekends after whatever day job I
had at the time so that's been really
hard but now it's fun
yeah yeah thank you for sharing it all
right
I see my energy is critical already I
already told you
okay Graham when it comes to Super space
Club can you can you tell us the premise
of the game and what was behind it
of course so
the premise is essentially you players
105 currently five
um anthropomorphic Heroes and you're
trying to defend the Galaxy against all
evil and yeah you're just vibing out all
the music that you hear in the game is
actually what the pilots are hearing so
you're just vibing out chilling while
you're defending the Galaxy so it's very
hectic but also it's a really
zen-like experience Destiny
um
then and I'm like oh my God they're like
oh
that's it
um of course asteroids is a big
inspiration for it
um but in this you don't actually get
hit hurt by the Astros that's all it's
just more of an aesthetic Choice like I
really liked how in asteroids you
you just thrust and whichever direction
you're going in you're facing that's the
direction you go and the physics
gameplay over to me just really
interesting to make and also to play
um and then yeah it's just I want to
make something that's just fun to pick
up and play within the first five
seconds of you diving in
yeah I know it is fun I'm just really
bad and I don't want to die and have
everybody watch me like
explode into a million pieces one of the
questions I wanted to ask is uh the
color scheme like
it's very like even though the game is
like very chill with the music and
everything I know I'm not conveying that
very well guys but it is very chill with
like the music but like with the color
scheme that's also very like calming
like did you do that on purpose oh we're
on Wave two oh my God that means I
survived wave one okay sorry
so it's funny when I when I first
started making it it was all black and
white just because my previous game was
very colorful I want to try something
new
and then I watched Spider-Man into the
spider-verse and I was like nah this
means oh super colorful nice and so yeah
let's put all the colors it's made it
very vibrant and I mean I think space
should be more colorful you know like
dark black and white spaces so overdone
like I don't think anything is out there
that looks like this that has this kind
of vibe so it visually and musically so
that's how the colors came to be
no I I absolutely love it and then you
oh okay aha y'all missed uh then when
you were talking about enter the spider
verse I was like yes that's my stuff I
love that movie it's so well done and I
love things that are colorful and I'm
really glad yeah it's so good listen we
need a lot more black superheroes that's
not what we're here to talk about but
it's the same I I absolutely love this
oh oh I'm gonna die I'm gonna die it's
hard to ask questions and also live and
survive you know
um
um let me collect this Stardust because
I keep forgetting it there you go um I
just wanted to say that like I'm I'm a
huge like art fan right and so like my
whole thing is like when I see a game
like the first thing that gets me
excited is the aesthetic but with your
game like it's the aesthetic it's and
it's also the music and so I wanted to
ask you more about the music like what
went into creating the vibe with that is
that more like
um kind of like you know I wanted to put
some of my culture into it because even
though the music is like a very chill
vibe from the trailer you can tell like
there's a lot of influence from like
your culture into it and I thought that
was really dope
yeah definitely
um with the with the music specifically
I really wanted a a Lo-Fi hip-hop kind
of vibe and it's so funny because when I
first started working on the game that
wasn't really as popular as it is now so
to me that was like a fresh new thing
and then everybody got on this Lo-Fi
train but I think what makes it stand
out still is that every every track in
the game has vocals to it and I try to
keep it with different black hip-hop
artists I have a Jamaican reggae
or hitting the trailer rival and then I
even have this one track with a French
raffle Amazon she's sick she's her track
is one of my favorite oh that's so dope
that's really cool right
yeah of course that's that's my favorite
part of the game I couldn't there's no
way
I love that yeah I want to pick up the
soundtrack shout out to fight Barbie in
the game and the game as well the
Beautiful music
like I'm just glad I haven't died yet
new I just knew I was like not gonna
make it no no
she came in with these doubts and you're
doing just fine just fine yeah like I'm
really proud of myself guys
people play
and people died
so you're doing very well yeah
thank you I'm good at running away wave
three some people don't even pass away
of one what are you talking about
oh it's because I'm good at running away
for real
oh there you go so it's your strategy
you found it yeah
you know I'm curious with the with the
time that we have together I'm curious
were there any challenges that came
along through the through development
yes
yes yes challenges
honestly the biggest challenge was
when I didn't
um have a day job
it was very hard for me to actually
leave my nine-to-five come home and then
put another how much ever I was into
this because
I didn't record a job like so oh finally
there you go you made it
I never worked a job where I didn't have
to care like I actually cared about what
I did I used to work at Snapchat
and it's actually caring about designing
and stuff there but when I come home
it's very hard to go back on the
complete and sit down for another two or
three hours yeah and so it was hard to
do that but then the pandemic hits and
then all the black lives of it and I was
just burnt out I was so burnt out and
then I had a son and in the middle of
all of that having a black son is just
it was rough it was right so especially
if we want to talk about the whole
reason why black voices came into like
existence was because of the thing that
happened with George Floyd and being a
black male in America is it's stressful
and I don't think a lot of people
realize that who are like outside of our
community but like thinking about having
children and having black sons that's
really important so I'm glad that you
brought that up especially when you're
trying to be creative and you also have
a daytime job and you also have a family
like I'm super proud of you like this
game is incredible and you've done such
an amazing job by like bringing it full
uh full force like I don't know what
else to say I I just think you did a
really great job I agree it creates like
a really positive outlook on the future
development and the future of black
voices in games so shout out to you
being a part one of my Googles I'm
trying I'm trying to set a good example
for people like me especially in Jamaica
or all over the world who didn't know
that this could be a thing
awesome well we're
of our time if people want to find out
more about you where can they look you
up
you can look me up at gram of Legends on
everything Twitter YouTube Facebook if
that's the thing you want to look up
anywhere just look up Grandma Legend and
go to superspaceclub.com you can
wishlist the game now and you can go
play the demo
awesome thank you so much guys remember
to wish
you wish so so important at steam know
that hey this is up and coming and it's
popping so if you like any of the games
that you see on here if you loved any of
them and they're not available yet
please wish list them we appreciate it
and Graham thank you so much for taking
time out of your day thank you for
coming on and talking with us
thank you Graham it's great to see you
listen I made it to the
pretty excited
excited so that means when you pick up
the game We're not gonna say I'm gonna
die a whole bunch because we're actually
just no we're just not the way I'm gonna
be a professional
pro at all of them at all of them you
saw that like
but yeah no that was that was fun that
was really good especially for a game
that like I've never I've never really
played that type of game so I'm feeling
very pumped that uh I got that far and I
will be wish listing it and uh I can't
wait for the soundtrack to come out
because I'm gonna be playing that even
when I'm not playing the game yes
absolutely I I can't wait uh I challenge
you that when the game comes out we see
which wave we get to what how far we can
get in these waves because I if I
remember in that trailer it gets to a
pretty high number so uh okay okay bet
you're on you're on this has been an
incredible show to be able to speak with
all the devs to see these trailers I'm
excited and I've been adding everything
to my wish list Destiny how about you
I've been adding everything to my wish
list like I don't just look I don't just
say just say things I'm about
it so I definitely added things to my
wish list and I hope you guys did too
because I mean like you've said like a
million times it helps the Developers
it does it does but before we're done
for the day we'd like to give another
shout out to our partners for this
showcase
I want to give an acknowledgment to our
silver sponsors and that includes
PlayStation look I was raised on
PlayStation and Final Fantasy 9 is still
one of my favorites
ID at Xbox Xbox is my jam and I'm out
here playing Forza Non-Stop
and lastly Riot
um excuse me have you seen Arcane if you
haven't you should probably tap in
our other sponsors include raw Fury who
helped get this series started so
without their support that black voices
in gaming would have not accelerated
from just a program to now a non-profit
organization
Razer for all the laptops and resources
that have helped support our developers
and lastly Wilson sancini the legal firm
who's getting into the action when it
comes to video games we'd also like to
say thanks to Amazon for the support
during black history month and a
celebration of black game developers
through their Prime gaming bundle and
the games of that month
along with that we'd have to say thanks
to Humble Bundle who continues to
support us in the devs we really
appreciate y'all to help celebrate Black
History Month they've put together a
collection of games called the black
creators and characters game bundle it's
incredible and if you're familiar with
waking uni games you might see something
on there
that's a shout out to Amazon Prime
bundle and the Humble Bundle make sure
to grab that phone snag those QR codes
while you can
lastly we have our broadcasting Partners
that's a special thanks to Twitch gaming
IGN steam Gamespot and game jolt
awesome and I I heard something about
waking Oni and their game so guys
definitely go check that out because uh
the person right over here over here I
don't know which way he is he's the one
who created that game so uh make sure
Shameless plug it's almost perfect Prime
game right the prime prime but uh before
we completely end and wrap this up don't
forget to check out the mix event page
on Steam where you can learn more about
the bvig titles by the available games
and or add them to your wish list wish
Let's Help the devs a ton so be sure you
add the ones that you like
also one of the most amazing things
about black voices in gaming is that
this has gone which we've said before
it's gone from just a showcase to a
non-profit and it's helping developers
reach their dreams of creating and
releasing their own games if you'd like
to help support some of the games you've
seen today and in any of our other
showcases be sure to take a moment and
donate to the black voices in Gaming's
tiltify remember grab that phone so you
can catch that QR code
that's right and if you're interested in
supporting black voices in gaming
through some of our merch or slide a
t-shirt to one of your family members
like I did check out the black voices in
gaming merch website if you'd like to
keep up with the bvig family you can
follow black voices in gaming at bvig
aiming on Twitter that's BVI gaming on
Twitter
then there's black voices in gaming on
IG and everywhere else check out black
voicesandgaming.org as well
a lot of gamings and ands in there and I
think you that was flawless I just want
to give you your props for that because
I probably would have messed that all up
but gave it my best shot no you did you
did an incredible job nobody could do it
better honestly uh guys I just want to
say thank you so much uh we already said
our thank yous to everyone who helped us
put this together but also uh let's just
give a huge shout out to all the
developers who are brave enough to come
on and show us their games I know that's
not easy and we're super proud of you
keep doing the things that you're doing
uh the people that we have on bvig never
cease to amaze me with their creativity
and hard work it has been an absolute
joy to get to talk to each one of them
and share their incredible games
projects and their Journey if you saw a
game today that got you really excited
be sure to wishlist it I'm gonna say
that all day every day make sure that
you wishlist it follow those developers
on their social media platforms and also
hit us up tell us what you thought as
always it's been a blast I loved hosting
with you Derek my name is Destiny and
you can find me at
dnbc32 over at Twitter or check me out
over at level one gaming
Destiny it has been a joy to host this
show with you and celebrate the games
that have been seen here on black voices
in gaming to become a non-profit we
celebrated this and mentioned this once
before but it's an incredible journey
for this show and I'm excited to see
what other developers uh what what new
developers we have in store as we
continue to support them if you're
interested in supporting black voices in
gaming we've said it profusely but we
mean it when we say that uh providing
donations through tiltify or risk
wishlist wish listing these games wish
listing is the best way that you can
support these developers
it's an important way to get these games
seen and heard and that's the entire
Mission behind black voices in gaming
my name is Derek Fields And if you're
looking to follow me because I love
rambling about PlayStation 2 games
mostly that's at the Derek V fields on
Twitter and everything else on social
media
oh my God you know what I I think that's
a wrap until next month because we have
another showcase coming in March so guys
please stay tuned we have lots more
talent and we're gonna keep this thing
going love you for loving us and uh
we'll check you out next time
[Music]
thank you